Do you ever wake up in the middle of the night
and wonder if you don’t have a similarly
sleepless friend that might be up for a game
of Boggle?
I know I do.
Hey guys, a sort of tired Amy here with you
on DNews today.
If you’ve ever woken up in the middle of
the night and been unable to fall back asleep
because your mind is racing with all the things
you’ve got on your to do list you’re certainly
not alone.
The middle of the night sleepless panic cycle
is one some of us know all too well, but why
do we wake up in the first place and suddenly
go into panic mode?
Panic attacks aren’t simply moments of anxiety,
thinking about that deadline that’s coming
up a little faster than you’d like.
Feeling shaky, short of breath, or dizzy can
be a sign that you’re having a panic attack.
But there are also physiological effects to
panic attacks, including an increased heart
rate and vascular reactions that can lead
to a tingly sensation.
Panic attacks can come on completely without
warning.
You can be watching TV and be hit with an
array of symptoms including increased heart
rate, shortness of breath, and an acute fear
of dying completely without warning.
Our subconscious mind is a big part of the
problem.
After experiencing something traumatic that
led you to panic, your subconscious mind can
mimic that pattern and send you into panic
mode once you’re removed from the situation.
And because panic attacks can be brought on
at the subconscious level, you don’t have
to be awake to experience one.
Panic attacks can hit when you’re asleep,
sometimes sparked by dreams or nightmares
that call back to the same subconscious patterns
that bring panic attacks on for no reason
while you’re watching TV.
The psychological and physiological reactions
-- rapid heart rate, shortness of breath,
dizziness, and sweating -- can combine to
wake you up and persist for minutes.
This can start a cycle of insomnia: you worry
about what will happen if you lose sleep,
but can’t sleep, so you worry more.
Being isolated in a dark, quiet room (i.e.
your bedroom at night) doesn’t help alleviate
the sudden stress of waking up in a panic.
Dealing with panic attacks isn’t easy, but
there are some tips and tricks to breaking
the midnight insomnia cycle.
Experts say that getting out of bed, out of
your bedroom, and doing something to dispel
negative thoughts until you’re really tired
enough to fall asleep is best.
Do you guys have any tricks for dealing with
those late night bouts of sleeplessness?
Let us know in the comments below or you can
catch me on Twitter as @astVintageSpace.
And don’t forget to subscribe for more DNews
every day of the week.